and our leaders with Christian in studio
Irene I came to the studio yesterday and
we were discussing your head to head
that you were behind zero two and you
said I have the chance to improve that
score and you came today with such an
aggressive stance you played the delayed
benoni and you got what you wanted how
do you feel right now yeah I feel really
good I mean obviously if that's uh
that's the result I was aiming for today
I mean it's hard to understate I start
to overstate the importance of this game
you know when you're half a point behind
there's only two rounds left
and um you know what I've learned over
the years I think I kind of alluded to
that yesterday is that you can't expect
anyone else to do your work for you you
know if you want to win the tournament
and you have a head-to-head battle like
you have to take your chances there
because hoping that your opponent like
someone else will get a draw off of them
or slow them down
um yeah that's not that's not productive
right so I kind of came in trying to uh
to do this myself today and yeah my
opening
um I think was uh was was good for the
moment it was indeed and you got into a
very nice position after she decided to
take on E6 and change the structure were
you still familiar with this position
yeah I was familiar with this position
but after Bishop E2 like this is where I
had like a 15 minute think after a
knight C6 castles
I first think of the game and actually I
was pretty happy with what I came up
with just like
um you know simple developing move B6 so
you just have to kind of figure out how
you want your pieces to be overall this
game I mean yeah it was definitely
always
um like black in Black's favor
um but there were some moments of course
that made it like technically tricky to
win we can keep going over the
strategical details that you were aiming
for in this position yeah I mean well
here's the thing I mean I got everything
in with like bonus tempos in this game
because I got to put I mean 91 certainly
cannot be you know the way to play this
position
um you know I got to have my knight on
D4 then white spent another Tempo with
the bishop on D3 so there were two
tempos to get the Knight to C2 where
it's not even clear what it does
differently from F3
um and then Bishop B2 to D3 so basically
I just got up you know fantastic
position and
um I had time to put my pieces on all
their best squares and started to play
on the king side
and here yeah I mean E5
um I don't know I decided that it was
time for this move I was looking at
things like Knight B8 to C6 here as well
like I don't know I thought maybe I
should try to bring another Knight to D4
but you know ultimately why I went for
E5 was because I wanted to play against
the light squared Bishop
um F5 yeah I see the computer sewing
this move you know honestly I didn't
even think this was tactically possible
it kind of looks like it just gives away
a pawn right it probably is giving away
a pawn so yeah the computer goes from
like zero zero to like zero point minus
six it's a very hard move to play I mean
I would say almost impossible for white
to like you know figure out now is the
time for me to go F5 I mean Knight D5 is
a very natural move by white and you
also have such nice support of the night
on D4 with the pawn Steel on C5 and E5
yeah so she went for this position which
is kind of what I was expecting so I
took and here I really thought like I
was close to winning and
um I felt like it was a little uh unfair
that she had this amazing G3 trick you
know a couple of moves down I mean come
on like you know you think that she just
you know blunders right Rook F4 and then
to figure out that she has G3 I mean wow
that's like I mean I did not see G3 and
thank God that I you know thought for a
little bit before you missed yeah yeah I
did not see that there was G3 like when
I was calculating all of this and I
decided I mean I already kind of thought
I was winning because if she goes Bishop
E3 instead of uh King H1 then I just put
her in a pin with rookie eights and you
know she can't really get out of it yeah
like here there's just too much because
we have six point H4 so her you know um
so the pin wins but the fact that you
can go King age one and leave the back
rank open and then you just take a
bishop and she just goes to G3 it's a
kind of unusual idea I have to say right
like it's it's definitely possible to
miss that from a distance so once I
missed that okay I mean white uh black
is still better but obviously you're not
gonna win the game right away so I
decided to keep on playing
you don't want these dark squares
um
yeah I mean I how do you regroup
yourself mentally at that point well
well it's fine I mean yeah there's G3
it's a trick uh you got to keep going I
mean you're still better you still got
the dark squares the B2 Pawn is falling
the bishop on C2 is not great
um but it really became like a technical
thing right which of course you know was
not my plan uh from the outset and I
think you know she played uh quite well
interesting decision to go Queen E2 and
Sack the pawn like right here Queen E2
was not a very obvious move right that
she I mean I thought okay I was
expecting maybe bishop takes E5 but I
think probably her decision is the right
one yeah it is indeed yeah this was a
quite a good practical Choice by her
because the problem is for me to win
this position I gotta get rid of the
dark squared Bishop
yeah if I can trade then it's over but
the bishop and F4 is such a strong
Defender and it just wasn't uh it wasn't
so easy at all and it felt like she was
getting her initiative as well going on
the king side yeah I mean it's like she
can't do so much I mean unless I really
decide to go overboard but
this move rookie eight I mean I guess I
mean
um whoa whoa that did not expect such an
evaluation rookie I mean I'm trying to
keep the Rooks on the board so here yeah
H5
wow well I definitely didn't think I was
you know gonna be ever in trouble in
this position
um but yeah of course this H5 idea I was
seeing in fact you know like a move like
even before you know like if she goes in
fact right before uh Queen F3 I was
looking at age five here but the
difference is now I take with the rook
and then I get to play Queen F3 Queen E7
just in time and that I'm actually good
right so I was seeing these ideas but
yeah Queen F3 of course is stronger
because she makes me take with my bishop
and the e-file is closed and then she
goes H5 wow Checkmate going on if you
take with the Rooks yeah that's amazing
though I mean to think that black could
be worse here like from what well like I
mean even if Queen G7 what to go for the
exchanges yeah what was wrong with like
Queen G7 I mean oh is it is there F7 H6
H6 maybe no I think no I just like that
I just invade on the light Square it's
amazing and her Bishop actually comes
into the game
I mean I it was it was technically
difficult as part like I just felt like
of course I wasn't expecting to be worse
like in this line and I mean I tried the
problem is if I allowed The Rook trade
like if we go back to the Rook trade
and like let's say it would have just
played uh Bishop takes E5 instead of
rookie eight okay yeah like I mean I
just thought that this you know very
closely it was very closer quality like
because the truth is the B Pawn is
irrelevant and she's going to be playing
on the king side with H5 like why should
she lose this position she's not yeah
yeah this one seems very simplified yeah
and you decided to keep but that then
this stuff came on you know I saw these
ideas I had to check for that because
actually one last thing can we go back
for one second because in this position
when the queen was on E2 I also had to
check the move Queen D1 you know just in
case right because I now I can't take
with the bishop but again now I can take
with the rook and I survive right it's
like I was definitely aware of these
ideas and I mean yeah she just forgot
that the queen on the diagonal was still
protecting The Rook right so you think
it was just a blunder yeah oh yeah I
think she just she just didn't um she
kind of thought she was pulling the
queen away and queen F7 wins The Rook or
something and then she just forgot that
the queen is on the same day I actually
realized when she made the move or after
she made the move you know I honestly
didn't like look at her facial
expressions too much at that point I
mean I knew that it was a blunder and
the queen was holding the Rook so
um yeah I mean I think she realized it
pretty pretty quickly and of course
after that there's no way she gets to
Euro yeah my Bishop is so nice now it's
like defending everything so well and
you converted nicely Irina
congratulations uh good spot for you
you're going into the last round with
half a point lead but two competitors
playing against each other potential uh
to score a victory in that one how are
you going to approach tomorrow's game
against one of your good friends and
Rivals yeah I understand I know right
you know it's funny because I'm playing
three U.S women's champions in a row
yeah actually right I didn't I realized
that I've got Nazi Jennifer and now Anna
and wow I see I've played a lot of games
against Anna over the years
um and this is only classical games yeah
classical right so
well I feel good I mean you know in the
tournament you got to do your job right
that's the first thing so
um that's what I'm gonna do tomorrow
again you know just do my job with the
white pieces try to play good chess and
try to close things out guys any
questions congratulations Arena that was
really quite the tumultuous game and uh
it's something we expected we expected
fireworks and uh it delivered so good
luck tomorrow Arena